Well, one of the main
challenges that students coming
into this class are
facing is that for many
of them, the last time they
did an experiment in a physics
class may have been a
high school class where
the experiments were set up to
in a certain sense, just work.
So they could push the
button and get the data
and then learn something about
whatever the piece of physics
that was being studied,
whether it was colliding two
carts to learn about
conservation of momentum,
or swinging a pendulum to learn
about harmonic oscillators,
something like that.
Usually, the instructor
who taught them
that experiment set
it up in such a way
that the experiments
were themselves
were not the challenge.
It was learning the physics.
By the time students get to
their third year of the physics
major, they really know
an extraordinary amount
of physics.
And that is really
a secondary goal
of what we're teaching here.
Junior Lab is really about
the professional development
of the student as a scientist,
and that means things
like approaching a
difficult piece of apparatus
with an attitude
that you're going
to be able to get it
done, understanding
that anything you try is not
going to work the first time.
You're going to
have to debug it.
It's about keeping very careful
records of what you've done,
so that when you have to
go back and repeat it,
you can see what you've done.
There's a large number of
things that sort of add up to,
this is the way a
professional does
it, which is different than
almost anything they've
done previously in their
career as a physics student.
So one of the
great challenges is
if they think they know
how to do experiments,
they may have learned it in a
way that was a little bit more
of a novice approach before.
So there may be some
things they have to unlearn
before even getting started.
And we spend about the first
month of the class working
on things like that.